We saw earlier that we could add
a map fragment or a layout file and
set properties on it to get some
pretty interesting and cool maps.
We even had a 3D fly over of New York
city that was pretty cool right?
Well that just scratches
the surface of the types of app
that you can build with map integration.
The XML based maps always
start in the same location and
that can be limiting for a mobile app.
So in order to get
a little more power and
flexibility, we're going to switch gears
and start using the Google Map objects
to compliment the map
fragment using Java code.
Once we've gotten that, it then becomes
really easy to set properties and
respond to user events on the map.
Let's start with an example where
we set the different map types
such as the standard map,
the satellite view or the hybrid view.
In this app,
you can see a map of New York City.
And I have control
over this map by touch.
I can panoram the map, and as you can
see, I can pinch to zoom in and out.
When I press the buttons at the top
of the map, Map, Satellite and
Hybrid, I can change the map type.
So if I touch Satellite,
I now can see details of the buildings
taken from Satellite images.
Here you can see Madison Square Garden
and even when I zoom in I can
begin to see some of the seating
plans in Madison Square Garden.
And of course Hybrid gives
me a hybrid of the two.
I can see satellite but
I can also see data such as landmarks
like the Empire State Building and
street names such as Fifth Avenue,
as you can see here.
I've done all of this using a Google
map object in my Java code.
This is slightly different
from the fragment that
you used in the earlier sample.
And we're going to dive in to take
a look at how to do this next.